deep into the favelas military police
patrols are now constantly on the
streets of gang controlled areas they
usually keep out off there is a
crackdown here and anyone indeed
everyone is a suspect stop and search
teams fan out from the patrol vehicles
securing the area in Brazil the crime
gangs are heavily armed and they are
prepared to defend themselves it's an
urban conflict as dangerous as any war I
take it this as a standard operation is
it very dangerous here yeah motorcycle
teams and multi vehicle patrols swoop
into the dark narrow streets unannounced
the city a fort aletter
is one of the first to experience the
determination of the country's new
president to fight back against gang
violence I think they're gonna move I
think we're on our way again it's a
absolutely constant this
no sort of basically crashing into area
as quickly as possible areas they know
are dangerous in areas where they know
there's gang activity that whole area is
gland control so ter they go to specific
points where they know they keep weapons
or drugs or deal from him roadblocks are
now common in areas where crime gangs
carry out their business they check the
vehicles for weapons and drugs local
police are now being supported by
heavily armed national police drafted
into the city in their hundreds clear
message that the new government intends
to impose itself and this is why a
campaign of violence against the state
orchestrated by gang leaders furious at
a security crackdown in prisons where
they're being held the gangs have blown
up bridges hijacked and destroyed buses
bringing public transport to a
standstill
they've hit water and electricity
supplies and in groups attacked a series
of garages setting them alight federal
bullets here like in England don't have
this this function you don't see this
often the Justice Minister packs a gun
elected to office he is actually a
detective specializing in organized
crime and drug trafficking he's overseen
the response here and he like many
others want more power cron and violence
as they've seen should he says be
classified as terrorism so basically
what you're saying is it is terrorism
but because of the law it isn't
prosecuted as such yeah and if you yeah
sort of a different crime yeah and you
would like to see that change so you can
actually be stronger yeah all of the we
have a College of the secretary we have
put secured of all states is our
interest that the
the law we have to be changed but this
president might do it we expect yes the
truth is imposing law and order in
Brazil isn't easy and it will cost a
fortune in personnel and resources here
it's been difficult enough in Rio and
Sao Paulo where the gangs are the size
of armies it could be nigh on impossible
still Ramzi Sky News for to letter